career earning for somebody like you
what is courier earnings for somebody
like you what kind of money did you make
in wrestling wrestling when it was all
said and done
probably made close to
six or seven million and what did you
make outside of it while you're
wrestling i'm talking like sponsorship
you know stuff like that did you get a
lot of that as well
there was some but nothing that was
significant but since
then
like i can say it took eight years for
it it took eight years in wrestling
before i made money before my you know
career blew up it was an overnight
success same thing with ddp yoga and
then eight years and
i've made
eight times that eight times that yeah
just from your program but maybe maybe
six six times 40 million bucks that's a
lot of money that's solid money to be
able to do that in wrestling who's the
highest paid of all time like who's made
the most money the goat is rick but i
don't think rick's the highest i mean i
gotta put the rock up there i would say
i would say hulk because remember hulk
rocks rock if you take overall wealth
the rocks the king the rocks
the rocks the mack daddy because he's
making 30 million dollars a movie now
you know you see i'm talking strictly
not outside i'm talking strictly
from the uh wrestling world i would
gotta say
over here i would say john cena would be
up there sure
uh but um i would say hulk would have
been upstairs all the time though that's
just for the year yeah i'm curious to
know what the all time is i'm curious
you know like if it's
you know uh all-time
highest
paid
wrestler i'd be so curious to know what
it what the okay there you go mick foley
18 million chris
jericho 18 million keep going
kurt angle 25 million interesting you
got hulk 25 million yeah but i think
that's net worth now what they think
that's the net worth you know and i
don't really know how much of that is
because these these are just numbers
people kind of pull together vince is an
easy one to figure out triple h wouldn't
be up there triple h oh he absolutely
would be
absolutely like
but again he also is part of the uh
you're if you're talking just wrestling
though yeah like money you made up just
wrestling because because it says rock
is worth 400 but it's not from wrestling
right yeah
it's on everything yeah but without his
wrestling without his wrestling base
rock's not the right oh my god no i mean
yeah when i saw him do saturday night
live the very first time i said i said
to myself gonna be the biggest star in
the world you knew that knew it because
he can do anything like he taught
himself guitar like there's such things
that the rock did like he would
it's amazing some of the things that he
came up with like he wrote a song
you know and he'd take a six song like
crazy funny stuff that that and he just
is just an amazing performer like he has
changed and opened the door
for wrestlers as actors like people
can't because wrestling people a lot of
people look down their nose well guess
what hollywood the biggest star in the
world's
a wrestler
and not a guy who walked away from it
still does so much stuff for us he's got
a show on tv called young rock you know
that he produces as a kid him as a kid
with all the wrestlers he never
turns his nose away
from his
fan base where it all started and but
the rock's the most loved guy on the
planet i honestly god believe and i know
it's i said this way a long time ago but
he could be the president united states
we talk about that all the time yeah and
the any but in serious discussion by the
way but do you really want that and you
know what
he might i don't know
but i think he would be amazing i
remember one point they were kidding
around about it and saying tom hanks is
vice president i think that we they
totally kill everybody there what do you
think about that video rock dude calling
out trump where are you where is he yeah
he kind of almost sounded like batman
you know he went straight to trump bro
yeah and you know i i that it took balls
because all those freaking red guys they
love him well that kind of pissed a
bunch of them off yeah but yeah when
people say to me like you're a
republican or a democrat i say i think
you both suck
you know i don't think he but either
one's trying to help the other which is
us
the other not trying to help us they
don't give a [ __ ] about themselves and
their own agendas and they all lie
about everything and never get busted
you know it's mind-boggling trump would
make appearances at wwe would he not he
i think didn't he fight vince mcmahon
he's a free he is in the celebrity wing
hall of famer yeah have you ever had
have you ever had to have you ever
interacted with trump has you ever been
there when the whole wrestling there i
never was there when he was doing that i
met him once when he literally first got
with his wife and it was at a elizabeth
glacier 8 foundation thing and it was
super nice
he was super nice you know the guy
you know
i i hated the stuff he did on twitter
and now the big whole thing with elon
and twitter and everything but
you know i hated
because he really could have just turned
the curb he could have turned the curve
once he got in there because he's a very
charismatic cat you know and
you know he could have been i to me
could have been much better
at doing the president thing
you know and trying to pull us together
you know but it is what it is again i
think all politicians are [ __ ] if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you